it's very hard when you go up against
somebody that shows up every flipping
day where you sit there and say take a
damn week off
go on vacation
why don't you slow down for a day or a
month or two months or three months
please let me catch up and he or she
says
come on down baby
i'm not taking that day off for the week
out for the month off that's why i'm the
dominator that's the mindset of a
dominator so for you watching this year
couple challenges i got for you number
one is
make a list of the guy that's the
dominator the competitor i just talked
about and see that intimidating quality
and see if you can apply to yourself
number two categorize what is a great
good bad terrible day for your field and
the business that you're a part of and
then based on that go out there and make
a massive plan of action because if you
create that momentum not going into 2022
you're probably gonna have a great 2022.
so if this message resonated with you
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel